so three people can go to the same exact
restaurant and look at the whole thing
from a complete different lens one can
go and say i just want good food and
good service another person can go and
say i wonder if this waitress is gonna
do a good job because they used to be a
waitress and they're watching all their
mannerisms another person can go in and
say look at the way i walked in the menu
the chef the plates how they're lined up
because they own a restaurant today
i'm gonna give you a lens to look at
data in a way maybe you've never looked
at before
[Music]
okay so stick around to lavarian i'm
going to give you a pdf on how to go use
this with your employees your team your
staff so you can get better data and get
better results to drive your company to
newer heights let's get right into it
there's four different ways to analyze
data the first kind is the descriptive
analytics then it's diagnostic analytics
then it's predictive analytics then it's
prescriptive analytics the first one
descriptive analytics is basic you're
researching and summarizing historical
data in order to identify patterns
how many sales do we do in the month of
january compared to february compared to
march it's very basic it's very
descriptive number two is diagnostic
which is understanding why behind what
happened why do we have a bad march
versus last year what happened what were
the events what happened did covet
change it the new laws come out did we
lose a customer did we gain a customer
what happened there so it's the why
number three predictive analytics says
studying those to to predict what's
about to happen next well the way we did
last october and the way we're trending
this
q3 versus last year q3 this october
we're probably going to end up only
doing 2 million so we're only going up
doing 3 million or we're poised to have
the biggest month ever because we have
this but if you look at the data and you
see patterns that you're not happy about
your numbers and you look at the
predictive analytics saying oh my gosh
if we go the way we're going we're gonna
have a bad october that's when you come
up with prescriptive analytics to say
what changes do we need to make in order
to change results you would be amazed
how few sales people sales leaders
executive and entrepreneurs actually
look at data this way i'm telling you
here that there is a level you will hit
if you don't look at data the right way
so now let's take a look at the next
side which is different forms of charts
to look at numbers i remember the moment
tom came to my second
you know
tracked my credit score back in the days
when in 2003 i started tracking my
credit score every month on the 18th i
would go to truecredit.com my credit
score was 484 495 and 4.99 i raised that
to an 820 but i tracked everything but
that was a very basic way of doing excel
we're going to look at in a completely
different way
so number one from line chart all the
way to the highest which is technical so
what is a line chart analyzing numbers
over time you're looking for trends and
it's one dimensional pretty much the
chart you're looking at on the screen
that's what it's going to look like okay
column chart you're comparing 2021 to
2020. it's a vertical chart you're
comparing you know may of 2020 versus
may of 2021 okay q1 of 2020 versus q1 of
2021 basic stuff so far you've probably
seen both next one is a bar chart so bar
chart and column chart are pretty much
the same thing the only difference is
column chart is vertical bar charts are
horizontal and maybe you can add a
little bit more to a column chart with
different categories like maybe it's one
or two or three categories you can add
age you can add different things to it
now we go to pie chart pie chart you
look at exactly what it sounds like it's
a pie chart so
you sold a million dollars of real
estate okay what percentage was it homes
between 0 to 420 what percentage was
from 420 to 720 what percentage was 722
million million to 2 million 2 million
and up right so that's the pie chart pie
chart can look at a lot of different
things you ate food today what did you
eat how much carbs how much protein
everything with that is a basic pie
chart you've probably seen that before
next is an area chart which is a line
chart at the bottom plus a bar chart
combined so it looks something like this
where the coloring tells you how you did
what the sales was so slightly more
technical because it's telling you now
multi-dimensions of data combined
together then you have pivot tables
which pivot tables are they seem simple
but a pivot table with somebody that
knows how to use excel spreadsheets they
have formulas behind them it could have
a you know if you punch in a number in
there the formula is already calculating
it to say well if this is what you did
based on the formula that we use and the
commission that we pay out we're going
to make 780 000 and you can kind of play
with it to know if we did this much
numbers here's how much money the
company would make okay so that's the
pivot chart and then you have scatter
chart which you've probably seen the
scatter chart with the dots on it what
that looks like that's kind of that's
comparing two numeric values it could be
cost and quality and uh there's a lot of
things that you can track with a scatter
chart then we have area map which some
call it scatter map this is kind of like
how you know we were trying to find out
covid what state has the most uh people
with covet cases and then it would show
to you region if i want to know what
country has the most covert cases you
would typically see that on a scatter
map if you want if you want to find out
what zip code has the most six figure
earners if you want to find out where
crime is the highest you know they would
use a scatter map very effective and
last but not least a little bit more
technical but it's a tree map chart it's
broken into subcategories you know maybe
you want to categorize your real estate
loans that you did what different loans
you sold you know what different
products you sold you may be a financial
company you do loans you do real estate
and you do escrow and you do insurance
so maybe loans is going to be read and
within the loans it's going to sell you
know you did an interest-only loan and
then you did a 30-year fixed loan and
you did a 15-year loan so it'll show you
which one of that is the most then real
estate sales unit it can categorize it
as well escrow can categorize it
insurance it can categorize it all on
one sheet right so i can go a little bit
more detail than data i don't want to do
that with you i want to keep it simple
but this is what i want to do to you
while you're looking at this
for me i'm growing my business i'm a
sales guy sales person you look at basic
data it's not complicated data then you
go become a sales leader and you try to
drive your guys through just you know
motivating them you can do more you can
do better try this script try this
overcoming objection but then you have
to go look at their trends and i
remember the things that changed because
i came up with something called dma you
know daily monitoring activity where
everybody had a specific date of how
many calls they made how many
appointments they ran and then we broke
it down to how many they closed based on
their closing ratio to see how hard they
were working accountability went higher
effectiveness went higher everybody made
more money
then you go into becoming a you know a
ceo a founder you start a company and
then you get to a million dollar level 5
million level 10 million level 20
million dollar level almost each level
you go to your plateau if you don't
unpack based on the right kind of data
you're not going to know why your
company is slowing down you're not going
to know the root cause you got to get
deeper it's like solving an issue and
saying why do we have such a bad
customer service well it's because we
don't say how may i help you we say how
can i help you well because
i don't know we need to use a better
script no because it takes 48 seconds
before somebody picks up the call you
got to get that to six seconds but
because you're not tracking a date
you're not going to know that you say
you're going to follow up within 24
hours but 20 of the time you follow up
80 percent of the time you don't and the
only reason you don't have that data is
because you don't track that data so you
go layer deeper and deeper and deeper
and deeper to find out exactly the root
cause of what's taking place and if you
can't address it your business grows
having said that
if you got value from today's content
give it a thumbs up subscribe to the
channel if you want today's pdf text
award chart two three one zero three
four zero one one three two text the
word chart c h a r t not plural singular
to three one zero three four zero one
one three two and if you're
international click on a link below to
uh look at um uh to subscribe to the
newsletter and we'll send this pdf to
you as well and if you've never watched
a video how to strategize as an
entrepreneur click over here to watch
the video how to strategize as an
entrepreneur because it has a lot to do
with what i just talked about today take
care everybody bye
[Music]
you